LOHIM BESIINHE POL AND VIVEKMAAE
IN THE WAYT  VICE
PRESIDENT D.
WE NEED A SINGLE DAY VOTING ON
WE NEED PAPER BALLOTS AND WENEE.
MATCHING THE VOTER FILE.
HAVE ACHIEVED VICTORY.
SHOULD NOT HAVE ANY
FUCOMPLAINABELECTION INTEGRITY.
I WOULD'VE LEAD
THROUGH THAT LEVEL OTHEN ON THAY
THE ELECTION RESULTS, SERVED UP
TO THE PRESIDENTANTHATNTAN7TH,EN
MPAIGN PSUE AND
I THK THAT WAS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY.
>> FAMILIAR WIROHE SCI-FI
OWEICENT HAS NEITHER TH
AUTHORITY TO SEND LEN
GRESS, OR THE
AUTHOR SIMPLY DENY
ELECTIESULTS.
IS NOTABLE THASIE
-
2022, VIVEK RAMASWAMY SAEE WITHK
K  LAST YEAR HE
AND EDRUN LIHEAL
PUBLICANDON'T BELIE THATTION WA.
AND,THE
PNT SPEFIE
WR QUOTE,  PN
THAT I HAVE GREARESPECT RTHAT IS
CONSTIONTO RESIST
THE PRESIDENTS ATTEMPTS
HILARN
INST HOLD IN THEEN BVE OUR
D.
AT'S
MAFOR.ON T
HE HAS ALSO ENUITE A BIT
OF BACKLASH
DEMOCRATICGROM
A MODERN GRAND WIZARD OF
KKKIOWA ONAY.
BE A BLACK VOICE.T T
WE DON'TT WNAT BE AICE.
RALLY WORD F WM
ANY WORDS IN
ABRAHAY BOOK
I WROTE WALKING, A PRIEST
MORE COPS.EN HERE'S WHAT IT SAY.
ENING LINETHE REMEDY TO
PAST DISINNT
PRESENT DISCRIMINATION'SEON.
L TRY TOASU WHEN
MAKING THAT CRITTHEORY STUFFS.
MODEEF THE
TH ABRAM EX NN JOINS
ME NOW.
HE IS THE AU OF, AS RAMASWAMY WG
ANTI RACIST.
HE IS ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF
CENTER FOR ANTI  RACIST
RESOURTYTHANKS FOR BEING HERE, T
TO JUSGE REACT DE, A
CONGRESSWOMAN PRESSLEY TO THE
MODERN GRAND WIZARDS OF THE.
>>REDIBLY
IND QUITE T
Y.SSIBLY TOSENTERRORIST GROUP OR
AL GROUPS THEY DON'TNCK
PRESSLAVE RES OF
NTS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS,
ESPECIALLY IN THIS MOMENT WHERES
TERRORIST THAT OF OUR TIME,
NOKE ME.IN, AND ACWHO E KLAN HEH
LOOK, YESTERDAY ON CNN'
E OF THE WD ABOUT THIS.
PRESSED ABOUT TH THE, AND HOW TD
POSSIBLY COMPARE TO ANYTHING
AT YOUR
BUT HE SAID THE O
A, QUOTE, HONEST
SCTHIS COU.
S , WHAT
ULD IT HONESN
RACE IN THIS COUNTRY AND THIS
MOMENT ACTUALLY OKE?
>> ID START TH
CI DISES.
WE WOULD IDE PLET'S SAY BLACK PE
KEO BE IMPOVERISHED WEREATED ORY
LI ODY
NOTHINGTALSO RECOE
P
BLI AND
TI LEADING TO
THOSE DISPARITIES.
CANS WE SHOULD COME
T CONVERSATIONTHOSE DISPARITIES.
BASED ONAND BASERACIAL
LITY>> OF
INIONS I THINK HERE BETWEEN
YOY ABOUT WHETHER
IT
NGR TO ADDRESS THEM IN TFUTURE.
FROM HIMOEVERSATIO
HAPPENING ON THE CAMPAIGL.
S AVOLHE IS DOING REALLY WELL AL
PART OF WHY HE IS RIW?
>> WITHOUTUEUNRTY YOU HAVE TOO Y
RE,DATES, IC
O REGN IN WHICH THEY C SORT OF
BOOST TO THE RIGHTLLING  NRACIS.
CANDIDATE BE BOOSTED,G THE O ARI
LY CANDIDAS COLOY ESSENTIALLY FG
E REPUBLICANS THERE AND TH IS AN
R AT